hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar tips and tricks for automating
viscous liquid handling i am sydney
mcneil of lab roots and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labruz and brought to you
by opentrons to learn more visit
opentrons.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of our
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation i'd
like to now welcome our speaker
honorable kanase process development
scientist opentrons honorable you may
now begin your presentation
thank you sydney very much thank you
everyone for joining today's seminar and
in this seminar i would like to
introduce you to understand the
different properties of viscous liquids
and how we can use uh automated liquid
handling and optimize these
parameters so after handling the viscous
liquids you'll your
the parameters you'll be able to
accurately handle viscous liquids using
the ot tube able to reduce the reagent
wastage and avoid cross-contamination
across your deck and finally improve the
reliability of the protocols running the
viscous liquids
before we begin let me first introduce
you two important concepts in
concerning the viscous liquids the first
one
you see on the left hand side
is a picture containing a tip with
liquid which is glycerol dangling around
the tip so on the top region you see the
liquid is present inside the tip and
somewhere around the meniscus is broken
of the liquid and at the bottom the
liquid is dripping around the tip so
these forces where the liquid is
adhering to the lab where is known as
adhesion and on the right hand side uh
is glycerol being poured in the cap of
the body cap
so the forces which are holding together
the glycerol
or the intermolecular forces and the
bonds which hold together a glycerol is
known as cohesive forces we'll be using
these concepts further in the
presentation
as a basic guideline let's take an
example of how liquid flows through the
tip
for simplicity we are considering the
tip as a pipe
and on the left hand side we see a pipe
and the liquid is
flowing through the
pipe so when you're pressing the plunger
off
of your pipette what happens is the
liquid starts flowing and
and there are a lot of friction forces
at the boundary of the tip or the wall
of the tip and these forces causes the
liquid on the boundary region to um to
flow slowly so these forces which are uh
frictional forces are known as additive
forces in case of or this particular use
case and the liquid starts flowing in
the center the liquid starts flowing at
a faster space a pace uh so these forces
which mine the liquid to move further
are known as cohesive forces so now if
we start looking at the
flow profile of the liquid
which is on the right hand side the
maximum resistance is at the boundary
over here at the boundary of the tip
and
uh as we go towards the center where the
cohesive forces are or much larger we
see the flow pattern is more like in a
parabolic shape and at the center of the
there is the least resistance due to the
collision forces and on the wall the
maximum resistance to the additive
forces
now the strategy to handle viscous
liquid is to minimize or get this red
arrow as much as closer as possible
towards the
um
to the beginning of the meniscus which
means that
we have to align the uh ratio between
the
adhesive forces and the cohesive forces
for having an effective flow through the
pipette tip
now based on the relative ratio of these
adjacent and the occursive sources which
dominate inside the tip for a given
liquid we are going to characterize the
viscous liquid classes so we can uh we
have characterized viscous liquid
classes into
four different categories the first one
is glycerated liquids the glycemic
liquids are essentially glycerol like
liquids or more a baked term would be
sugary liquids so these example includes
honey and honey glycerol or pegs
um these kind of liquids have very high
adhesion uh high adhesion and high
corrosive forces
the second category is volatile viscous
liquids an example would be beads
hydrophobic coatings or hand sanitizer
so these liquids have very high adhesion
to the tip and neutral collagen to the
liquid itself
the third category is surfactant viscous
liquids these viscous liquids are
essentially soapy liquids or detergents
but they are
viscous in nature for example tween
buffer or triton x or liquid hand
washers
they show a very high quality
adhesion to the
tip wall but very low collision to
itself so that's the particular property
of the surfactant itself and the fourth
category is oils the an oil
example of oils may include mineral oil
engine oil or cooking oils in this year
very high adhesion to the
tip wall also very high adhesion to the
liquid
let's take another example of what
exactly happens when a liquid is
aspirated a viscous liquid is aspirated
uh when any robot or uh even the manual
pipettor ship they are tuned for for
best performance using water so if
you're going to use the same parameters
to handle viscous liquids
this is the case which is going to
happen this is a case of aspiration of
viscous liquid
the robot moves the tip quick pretty
fast and then it tries to aspirate the
liquid and it doesn't allow sufficient
time for the liquid to get aspirated and
we can see the liquid being incompletely
aspirated the droplets are form around
the tip
and there is filling of a reagent or
now let's look at
what happens if you're going to dispense
the same liquid
when we insert the tip
you can see that a lot of liquid was
wasted around the walls and
it's not the tip is not completely uh
dispense that was wastage of reagent and
overflowing reagent and such volumes are
non-duplicable so the idea is to
actually optimize these parameters based
on uh the flow rate of the liquid and
how the tip is being aspirated dispensed
and if there is any dispense time and
the withdrawal of the tip
so let's take a look at
how we can optimize any liquid
any viscous liquid for smoother liquid
handling
uh the idea is to first of all aspirate
uh have an aspiration flow rate to the
one tenth of whatever whatever your flow
rate was defined for
uh water so in open trans case we're
using uh 27 microliter for p1000
uh as the aspirations are microliter per
second for aspiration we delay for 20
seconds after aspiration and then we
draw the tip
at 400 millimeters per second
now
let's try to dispense it uh this liquid
at the same speed as what we are
dispensing water so what happens is the
meniscus is broken immediately and
the
the liquid or the plunger has completed
its complete dismiss displacement now we
see that some liquid is being
dispensed towards the bottom of the
meniscus and
the
liquid is not completely dispensed out
of the tip
so there is the next step is to reduce
the flow rate
now uh the idea is to get the minute uh
reduce the flow rate such that the
meniscus is gradually decreasing until
the mid of the tip
so we are using a dispensed flow rate of
one-sixth of water
and we're using the same blowout read
let's try to dispense at one sixth of
the read we saw that earlier the
meniscus was broken over here but now we
have broken the meniscus little below
but again we see it's
the liquid is not completely dispensed
out of the tip
and
now let's try to optimize it further
let's try to reduce the flow rate
now we are going to reduce the flow rate
to one tenth of the water flow rate and
add a delay of 10 seconds after the
liquid is being dispensed and then
perform a blowout
so the blowout which we are using is the
normal uh blowout and now we can see the
liquid is slowly dispensed compared to
previous and the meniscus is broken much
up below the tip
now after dispensing
a normal blowout flow rate was used and
still there is some kind of liquid uh
some liquid which is still present
inside the tip
now this is glycerol 1999
now
finally what we would like to do is we
are going to dispense at one tenth of
the water rate which we earlier realized
it's pretty good rate for this
particular liquid
added a delay of 10 seconds but we are
also going to decrease the blowout flow
rate which allows the liquid which is
settled at the bottom to slowly get
removed from the tip let's take a look
over here now we are slowly dispensing
the liquid
and now there is a delay for 10 seconds
and a slow blowout of
158 fifths of slip of water allowed us
to have a pretty good tip
let's take this optimized strategy for
viscous liquid handling so if you're
going to aspirate the liquid
move to the top of the lavender at the
default speed then move to the bottom of
the ladder at a slower speed which is 10
millimeters per second
and then aspirate at a slower flow rate
and add a delay so that the liquid which
is still being aspirated uh due to the
negative pressure which is being
developed inside the tip and the uh and
the plunger head
is allowing the liquid to get settled
towards the top of the tip or to the
maximum value a volume of the tip
and finally but draw the tip slowly from
the lavender at one to five millimeter
per second
further to dispense a viscous liquid
we're going to move towards the top of
the lab there and then move to the
bottom of the lava at 10 millimeters per
second this is to reduce any kind of
spilling of the liquid
which is already present inside the
ladder and then dispense at a slower
flow rate
further we are going to add a delay
uh for or or some kind of delay which
will help you
help the liquid to dispense
completely
and also settle down to the bottom of
the uh tip
now once there is residual volume
present at the bottom of the tip we are
going to remove this using a slower blue
rod and after using a slower blowout we
are going to withdraw the tip from the
liquid
at um at a slower flow rate which is uh
at a slower
of withdrawal rate which is one to five
millimeter per second let's take uh
example in the case of glycemic liquids
how we're going to handle the glycerin
liquids now uh so the common properties
of the glycemic liquids are
high cohesive uh forces and high
adhesion to the tip so there is a pretty
good uh synchronization between uh the
meniscus which is formed and the flow
rate so all you have to do for the
glycemic liquid is to tune them such
that uh the meniscus is not broken until
uh
until the liquid has reached one third
of the tip position or where the tip
actually starts narrowing down
so this liquid
if if there is any
to the tip it's it doesn't really remove
bob because there is no gravity being
acting on it
and now let's take an example of how to
optimize for glycerol 99
so the first step of aspirating the
liquid what i'm going to do is i'm going
to aspirate it at uh one tenth of uh
of the normal flow rate
and pro and after aspiration i'm going
to provide a delay of 20 seconds so that
the liquid is completely aspirated
inside the tip and then i'm going to
withdraw the tip at one millimeter per
second the viscosity of glycerol 99
percent roughly over here is
890 centipoise
so here i go
now we immerse the tip
and we aspirate at this lower flow rate
the video speed is like 8x
after the delay we are
slowly removing the tip from the liquid
therefore what we can see is the pipette
is able to highly accurately aspirate
the liquid it's very clean pipetting
there is no spilling around and no
droplets are formed around the tip
the only drawback over here is
longer protocol time
now let's take an example how we can do
the dispense cycle after the liquid is
being aspirated inside the
tip so for dispensing it the dispense
flow rate is one tenth of the uh default
display speed
air flow rate and uh the dispense delay
is 20 seconds so after dispensing we are
going to wait for 20 seconds and then
the blowout is being performed at 155th
of the default water uh water flow rate
and the tip withdrawal speed is one
millimeter per second so all these
actions can be performed using the
python api for open trends
here we go we are dispensing it at one
tenth
after the dispense is complete we are
waiting for 20 seconds now we were
drawing the tip a little bit above the
surface and blowout was performed
the withdrawal was done at open
millimeter per second and you can see
the tip is pretty clean
and there is no spilling around and
minimal droplets are beings sticking to
the tip so the idea to handle the
viscous liquid is lower your flow rate
reduce the blow out rate and add a delay
after your aspiration or dispense cycle
the most critical step
tip is to withdraw the tip at slowest
speed if the viscosity of your glycemic
liquid is really high for instance in
case of if you're going to aspirate
honey kind of liquid
now let's let's look at what happens
with the volatile viscous liquids so the
volatile viscous liquids are essentially
solvents which are mixed with some kind
of beet solution or maybe glycerol for
instance in case of hydrophobic coatings
or maybe beads or hand sanitizer would
be the best easiest example
so volatile uh viscous liquids have very
high adhesion to the
tip so they keep on sticking to the chip
but they have very little
but they have low corrosion to itself so
you can see the surface property of the
volatile liquids is really poor they
don't stick to each other
and the volatility may really vary uh
depending on the uh volatile liquid or
volatile solvent that's being used
the critical factor over here is to use
air gap
because
if you're going to dispense it
there is a jet going to form and the
liquid is still going to stick to the
wall
now let's take
an example of how we are going to uh
handle the hand sanitizer um or
which is having the viscosity of roughly
around 200 centipoise so we're going to
use similar parameters which we use for
glycerol and we're going to aspirate it
at one tenth of the default flow rate
uh then wait for 20 seconds after
aspiration and then we draw it at one
millimeter per second the good thing
about aspirating uh viscous um
solvents is they are little easy to
aspirate
now we are going to withdraw it
and as you can see there was no
droplet forming around the tip but we
definitely need an air gap to
uh to avoid any kind of spilling of
liquid if there is pressure built inside
the
upper cavity of the tip and the plunger
between the
top surface of the liquid and the
plunger
so
um we see a clean tip and there's no
spilling and no droplets are formed now
let's take a look at how we can dispense
it now
an important factor over here is as we
discussed earlier
uh these liquids um or volatile liquids
have very high adhesive forces which
means that the liquid is sticking to the
lava
or is that
has very high affinity to the lava so
what we are going to use a method called
as touch dispense in which what you do
is you move the tip to the wall of the
lavender and then dispense at
a slower flow rate which is the one
tenth of the flow rate default flow rate
add a dispense delay of 20 seconds and
then we are going to perform a slower
blowout
let's take a look at this example now
over here we are
doing a touch dispense where we are
sticking the tip to the wall of the
laptop
and we are dispensing now we are
delaying it for 20 seconds
and
we are going to perform the blowout we
can still see that there is some
residual volume which is sticking to the
tip the problem of the with such liquids
is either you can uh dispense it in
multiple steps like you dispense half of
the liquid in the tip and then allow the
liquid which has been sticking to the
wall to gradually settle down to the uh
to the orifice of the towards the
orifice of the tip this helps in
reducing your protocol run time but the
trade-off is uh you'll have a longer
protocol runtime
and there there will always be some
residual volume left but considering um
and just considering depending on the
application of your
of your protocol you can
consider what what the residual volume
is going to be
now let's take a look at the surfactant
viscous liquid
uh
the basic property of action viscous
liquids are they are surfactants or
detergents
uh
very poor surface tension and they don't
have any adhesion to itself or very poor
adhesion to itself but they have very
high adhesion to the labyrinth which
you're using they behave a little
similar to uh the volatile liquids which
we saw earlier and the examples would be
tween buffer or triton x which are
commonly used in our protocols and
the world's famous example would be
liquid hand cell
so if you're going to uh dispense this
liquid the common problems which
you might be having is there is
excess retention of liquid after the
viscous liquid is being dispensed so you
might need to
dispense in multi steps where you're
allowing the surfactant to completely
come to the bottom of the or the orifice
of the tip let's take an example of how
we we are doing this for
trident x
so the viscosity of triton x is around
230 centipoise we're using lower
concentration of dye just to avoid any
kind of bubbling problem
and these liquids have very easy
affinity for creating bubbles around the
liquid which might get trapped inside
your tick so it's always
a good recommendation that when you're
starting your protocol try to avoid the
bubbles
at your in your lab there itself
here you're going to use again one tenth
of the flow rate and the aspiration rate
is um
going to be one tenth of your default
flow rate your aspiration delay is going
to be 20 seconds and the temperature all
speed is going to be one millimeter per
second
so we're going to slowly aspirate
and we can see the liquid is being
aspirated properly
and
since
there
it it required
some liquid uh which was sticking to the
lava and the tip was um being touching
to the lava it caused some liquid not to
get aspirated uh it's it's again a
property of a
viscous liquid but when um of viscous
liquid but the basic property of the
surfactant handling uh surfactant
liquids is these liquids are very high
adhesive sources which means that
they'll keep on sticking to the lava
when you're aspirating it see
and
after aspiration there might be any some
kind of hollow gap which has been or a
hollow cavity which has been created
inside the liquid which may cause
a problem like a bubble being introduced
or air gap being introduced after the
liquid is aspirated
so just to make sure you're completely
going to aspirate and and wait until the
liquid has settled down
and then only withdraw the tip
so in this liquid we can see there is
clean pipetting no bubbles being
performed in the spilling around also no
droplets are formed but there is a air
gap problem which
depending on the need of your protocol
now let's take a look at how we are
going to dispense this viscous liquid
again coming back to
the affinity of
the liquid to the lavender we have to
dispense at the top because now when we
are dispensing this liquid it will
easily adhere to the top or the tip
itself when it is being dispensed out so
it's a good idea to dispense at the top
of the wall and then dispense at a
slower flow rate so that your the whole
liquid we are still able to maintain the
meniscus and the whole liquid is able to
flow cohesively towards the bottom of
the tip introduce a delay of 20 seconds
and if one dispense is not enough you
can add to this uh two distance of the
liquid or multi-dispense in which you're
going to split or the dispense cycle
into two parts for instance for p1000
you can dispense with 500 microliters
first and then again wait for some time
and dispense 500 microliters um during
the second time this increases your
protocol runtime but let's take a look
how this behaves
we're dispensing at the top of the
surface but you can see the liquid is
still taking some time to
fall towards the bottom of the tip
now we are going to perform a blowout
and over here
there is still some liquid which is
being retained inside the tip
so if
if
protocol runtime is a critical factor in
your protocol then uh it's a good um
good way to estimate what will be the
excess liquid or residual volume which
is being uh observed inside the tip and
then consider
optimizing your protocol uh based on the
residual volume or
based on the
performance uh if you want to compensate
uh
using the time of
faster time then use multi-dispense
steps or just consider there will be
some residual volume yet you can
dispense it at a very higher speed or
you have to if you want a complete clean
dispense then a longer protocol run time
will be a problem so that's a kind of a
trade-off between a faster protocol and
a slower protocol for surfactant liquids
in
like the residual volume versus the
runtime
final liquid class is oils so the oils
are
any kind of oils which are being used
for example it would be cbd oil mineral
oil or plants oil which are being
pipetted for your protocol purposes so
they have very high adhesion but they
also show very high cohesion to the
liquid itself so they do relatively move
to the tip but the problem is due to
very high adhesive sources
they keep on sticking to the wall of the
tip
slowing the flow rates allow easy
aspiration dispense so
generally it's pretty easy to aspirate
in distance at slower flow rates but
uh
again similar to surfactants oils also
retain liquid inside after the distance
cycle
so let's take an example of um olive oil
being dispensed the viscosity of olive
oil used over here is roughly around
centipoise 90 centipoise and what we are
going to do is aspirate at a slower flow
rate slowly withdraw the tip after
allowing a delay of 20 seconds after
aspiration
we've introduced an aspiration slower
aspiration flow rate allows some delay
and then withdraw the tip
in most of the videos you may have
noticed that
the liquid is
still being aspirated and suddenly the
tip starts moving up
the
phenomena which is happening over here
is the slow aspiration is
uh taking place inside the tip the
liquid is slowly being aspirated during
the delay cycle so you always
continuously see that even though the
robot is not running
or the pipet plunger is not moving but
the liquid is still climb
negative pressure and because of the
viscosity slowly and so this aspiration
delay time allows you for the liquid to
completely climb up the tip and fully
attain the desired target volume and now
we are going to slowly withdraw the tip
you can see slowly by drawing the tip
actually reduces a lot of droplet
problem and there is no
spilling outside your lab there so it's
a very good strategy to remove um for
viscous liquids or volatile liquids
it's slowly remove your tip outside
outside the lavender
in the next step what we're going to do
is dispense the same liquid
as i told you it has a very high
affinity to the
wall of the tip and oils also behave
similar to surfactants such that they
will keep on sticking to the tip inside
for a longer period of time so there
will be some
residual volume left but it's
less compared to what we saw in case of
surfactant and we are going to dispense
at the top just to take advantage of the
additive forces so that the liquid is
still quickly sticking to the lavender
while it is flowing inside the lab
from the tip so let's take a look
first step we go and dispense at the top
of the labware at a slower speed
this is a real-time video
so this is the amount of time which is
required for the liquid to get dispensed
properly
believe at this point
that um the dispense delay has already
started working on it
and so the flow uh blowout floor blowout
was introduced and you can see
there is very less liquid which is still
which can be observed right now
but if gradually alarming some time
then uh the oil which is sticking to the
wall of the tip will start settling down
to the bottom of the tip so there will
be some residual volume left and we have
to be mindful while optimizing our
protocol and again it's a pretty longer
protocol time so the viscous liquids in
general they have a longer run time but
if you are able to
uh
wait for that if you if you're able to
have a trade-off of that time you're
able to achieve really good and accurate
results to your target volumes for your
desired protocols
these are the examples of gravimetric
test results and this was done uh with
glycerol 19 a different concentration of
glycerol as they are represented classes
of our
viscous liquids because glycerol 10
percent has a viscosity of roughly
around
two to three centipoise and ninety
percent has a viscosity of roughly
around one sixty seventy point and
ninety nine percent has a
eight ninety centipoise so these uh
three different classes cover
a varied range of viscosity and
the gravimetric testing was performed on
on the these liquids using the p20 so
the results are very comparable to our
water results
or how p20 can handle water
as well as for p300 the results are very
similar to how it can handle water
in different liquid cases
for p1000 again it's a very similar case
uh the glycerol handling for 99.90 and
10
it's very similar the results look
pretty similar to water
so
um
we're able to
use the these kind of techniques to
definitely smooth and use the control
flow rate using the automated viscously
uh automated liquid handlers to handle
viscous liquids which are not that
possible if you're dispensing it
manually or if you're using manual uh
processes for
uh for your protocols so and we are able
to achieve accuracy which we showed in
the results part
which is very close to our water cv
and
this accuracy is very
accuracy for aspiration the dispense for
the desired volume
finally we're able to increase the
reproducibility in the results reduce
the reagent raise stage and do this
completely automated uh without any
human interfere uh interference
i would like to thank our testing team
carlos anders uh for helping in during
the testing time and i'm hoping to get
questions
thank you
thank you honorag for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for let's get started
our first question is
could you elaborate on mixing viscous
liquids
uh yeah that's a very good question um
mixing viscous liquids is a little
tricky up here it really depends on what
kind of lab where you're using so first
of all if you're going to use a very
uh tall lava for instance like 15 ml
tube or like 50 ml tube uh it's
and depending on the volume which is
present inside your lab where it's it's
difficult to mix
uh if the liquid if the volume inside
your uh 15mm fulcrum tube is to the
maximum so the idea is to go to the
bottom of the lavender and try to
mix it slowly several times one mix or
two mix is not really going to help you
mixing it start with the viscous liquid
uh and dispense into the lavender
and then dispense a less viscous liquid
mix it uh try to optimize your protocol
at mixing at slower flow rate which you
used for the higher viscous liquid and
once you are able to
achieve like uh try to
go through several mixing steps and try
to optimize your protocol uh based on
the two different liquids which you're
using another way is to
if your protocol is able to support um
to increase the temperature of your
liquid for instance if you're going to
use work with a 99 plus percent glycerol
and if you're able to uh heat the
glycerol or to higher temperature for
instance like 50 degrees celsius the
viscosity of the glycerol drops
gradually uh i think it drops at 50
degrees celsius it drops to like
around one fifth of whatever the current
viscosity is uh so it's a good idea to
increase the temperature if your
protocol allows you to uh
increase the temperature and then mix
together the viscous liquids
perfect thank you our next question is
what do you recommend to reduce bubbles
during blowouts especially in detergents
well uh very interesting question so
maturity reduce the bubbles uh during
the blowout the most critical step is uh
insert your tip to the
uh top of the uh lavender and dispense
it uh
do something as touch dispense but
also another important thing is make
sure your tip doesn't have any kind of
air gap so if let's say you're going to
dispense 100 microliter with p300 then
slowly immerse your tip on the top of
the liquid making sure that there is no
air gap and dispense
99 micro liter only because that one
micro liter uh
of liquid which is present inside your
tip won't introduce any kind of air gap
so that would be a good way to not
incorporate any kind of external air or
air which is already present in the tip
and just dispense the liquid uh almost
to 99
so that reduces any kind of bubbling
problem uh especially for detergents
great thank you
our next question could you comment on
changing pipetting parameters as the
temperature decreases and increases
liquid viscosity
oh yeah sure so if the
uh if you're going to decrease the
temperature of the liquid for example uh
if you're going to decrease glycerol and
uh i've tested this at 14 degrees
celsius with our temperate material so
the viscosity actually drops down pretty
significantly i think the viscosity uh
increases uh sorry
the viscosity increases um four times
whatever it was for at 25 degrees
celsius for instance uh compared to 14
degree so the idea is to reduce your
flow rate or there are some applications
which require you to
work at lower temperature for example
like pcr qpcr applications uh so a good
way to handle these kind of situation is
to slower the flow rate than what you're
using it for your current viscosity it's
also a good idea to look at the
viscosity chart and then compare your
previously used liquid and reduce the
fluid flow rate accordingly
um
and then draw the tip slowly and if
you're going to increase the uh
temperature then the viscosity is
decreasing so that you can take
advantage of a faster flow rate faster a
faster aspiration and dispense flow rate
now in this case your protocol runtime
is decreasing but if there is any
possibility of
damaging your uh your protocol if there
is any kind of sensitive matter a
material
then
it's a good idea not to increase the
temperature and keep working at the
prescribed temperature
great thank you
next question could you speak on the
touch tip function and how they can be
helpful in dispensing viscous liquids
sure so the touchdown function is
generally used um
when the liquid is still sticking to the
tip or uh like the orifice of the tip so
a good way to
uh try to remove uh like remove these
kind of
liquid droplets are using touch tips so
essentially what it does is the way we
do it manually like we keep on touching
the surfaces of the lava so as to remove
any kind of liquid which is being
attached to the walls
so the touchstrip essentially does the
same thing uh and it can like you can
perform touch type at different
locations inside the lava also uh
depending on the shape of your well it
is important to consider touch to
function for example if you're going to
use a v-shaped well and you're going to
use touch tip at the bottom then there
is a high possibility that you might
drop off the tip so
in viscous liquids use touch tip only
when uh
consider what the height you want to
use the touchscreen pad and use it only
when uh you if you observe that the
liquid droplets are sticking to the tip
this happens mostly in case of beads
where there is some kind of uh droplets
are being sticking out at the tip i
would recommend to use plush dispense
instead where you're moving your tip to
the edge of the lavender and dispensing
completely
perfect thank you
next question can the tips themselves
have an effect different companies for
example
um that's a very good point yes yes um
so
the reason tips have uh like
uh the reason why tips have
different effects on the way you're
dispensing is because uh first is the
profile of the tip the way liquid
handlers are programmed are using the
tip profile so
like your plantar displacement can help
you in dispensing it
based on your tip
if the tip has a larger bore uh the
plunger displacement can be faster but
if your tip has a slower blower then um
then it has a different slower uh
plunger displacement rate so also the
second property of the tip is what kind
of material what kind of plastic is
being used uh so generally there is a
lot of electrostatic
forces which are causing the liquid to
stick around the walls of the tip um so
if you're using a very good quality of
the tip quality tip
then it it would generally have lower
electrostatic forces which are causing
less
lesser droplets being sticking to the
tip uh and another factor is how good is
the packing of the tip to the
pipet so
using an incompatible tip is somewhere
where there is a small kind of air being
present um between your tip tip head and
the plunger
and the pipette so what happens is if
there is any kind of leakage you're not
able to aspirate it completely properly
so definitely the tip has uh like the
tip material or the tip shape or the
tip brand has a effect on the
uh on the liquid handling performance
and it's a good idea to use or try out
the tips try to test out the volumes of
the liquids using your gravimetric
methods and then only uh rely on those
tips which are which you think are going
to perform well with your liquid handler
great thank you
next question what liquid class would
matrigel and similar hydrogels for 3d
cell cultures fall in
uh that's a good question i think um so
the metri gel would be more like
it i think it would be a combination of
three classes and not really a volatile
class but still more like a surfactant
class because they are hydrogels and
volatile um
only because there is some kind of
retention inside the tip and um the
glycerol class so
i think the good way to handle uh
3d cell culture using the hydrogels is
first of all making sure that your tip
is able to um aspirate and dispense them
properly like there is no blocking being
performed uh the the tip is not blocking
these or the hydrogels or if they are
pretty larger in size they're not
blocking it so
uh that's that's the first uh step to
find out and the second thing is uh
going to be uh reducing the flow rate
for mutual and hydrogels and uh the
third step would be withdrawing it
slowly so i think uh using the first
three classes would be easy uh using the
touch dispense uh will definitely help
in removing the hydrogels from the tip
great thank you it looks like we have
one final question are the aspirate and
dispense settings in your presentation
standard for each type of viscous liquid
um
that's a good question it can be tuned
the reason i'm i have used
these standard functions or um
so we uh we definitely have these
functions in our app node please have a
look at the app node for different kinds
of liquids which we have tested
and currently the presented liquids are
more like they have been trusted
gravimetrically so we can pretty much
assure about these parameters uh the
reasons of like these parameters were
pretty much consistent are
because uh we found out like these
parameters works best but uh if you want
to have your different uh if you have a
pretty different liquid you can
definitely begin with the viscosity for
uh like the viscosity as a parameter and
then choose what what are the parameters
for uh such liquid so for instance if
you have if you're working with peg
which is not mentioned over here right
now in the presentation but uh in our
app notes we have something for pg so
let's say you are having a different
concentration of peg maybe like 25
then what you're going to do is um
try to consider or try to search for
what is the viscosity of this 25 percent
pvc or let's say it is going to be
50 70 point then what parameters work
well for centipoise 50 centipoise will
definitely help your understanding uh
um
in handling these kind of uh
unknown liquids and try to uh and the
first strategy which i showed you is to
understand how at what range or at what
rate you are able to
uh keep the meniscus constant this is a
good way to begin with so aspirate your
liquid at a slower flow rate and then
dispense at a slower flow rate and try
to keep the misconstant
until it reaches to where the tip starts
changing its face
or the shape profile of the head
i can take a couple of questions if
there are any
it looks like we did have one more come
through any particular tips for magnet
for magnetic beads pipetting
uh sure yeah so
again the magnetic beads are
different uh like based on the solvent
they are present in it could be like you
you might be having some kind of
glycerol uh present which are pretty
easy to handle using the glycerol kind
of parameters which we stated uh but
there are other beads which are placed
in some wallpaper or like ethanol or
some kind of detergent if any so
for ethanol it's a very critical thing
to aspirate the beads at a slower speed
and make sure they are mixed properly or
homogeneously and then aspirated at
slower speed and then um
use an air gap function because the
ethanol is going to drop so uh use some
uh like some volume of air gap five
microliters for uh p300 works well and
then
then move the tip to the desired
position
great thank you
one more question where can i find the
app note you mentioned will it be
included in the follow-up email
uh sure yeah we can send uh send out the
app note in the follow follow-up email
but uh the good idea would be uh to
look for the app note at uh
uh in our app notes section and opened
on opentron's website so you'll be able
to find out the app note for viscose
liquid handling on the opentron's
website keep an eye on the documents
section of the opentron's website
perfect it looks like that is all of the
questions we have for today honorable do
you have any final comments for your for
our audience
uh thank you very much for uh attending
today's talk and
um let me know if there are
there are any kind of questions if you
feel um
that there is something uh that you need
uh to be
covered or uh you need some assistance
you can definitely reach out to our
absence team and reach out to me in case
of any technical uh concerns if you want
your protocols to uh to be developed for
handling specific liquids uh our app
engine
and these protocols
can be handled pretty well only using a
python api the protocol developer has
some limitations at the moment we are
trying on improving the performance of
the protocol developer so the absence
team will definitely be able to help you
using the python api and please uh feel
free to reach out to melissa for any
product inquiries if you have any demo
requests of the od twos and if you
require any particular application uh
please let melissa know she'll be of
very
great help to you and thank you everyone
thank you again honor honorable for your
time today we would also like to thank
libras and our sponsor opentrons for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye